protests heat up for a second night
across barcelona
police stations banks and several stores
are damaged during demonstrations
thousands took to the streets to demand
the release of pablo hassell from jail
the rapper's lyrics and tweets got him
in hot water with the authorities
after he insulted spanish royalty
supported a now defunct
extremist group and criticized the
police
i'm a musician and it affects me the
fact that in spain
artists musicians rappers everyone is
arrested
i find it quite brutal that people are
arrested for the lyrics of a song
common sense tells me that i have to be
here because we have less and less
freedom in spain
on monday police stormed yada university
where hassell had barricaded himself in
with other activists
to avoid a jail sentence hassel was
taken away by police but remained
defiant
they will never make us give in despite
the repression
hassel's case has inspired support
across the country
200 prominent artists actors and
musicians
signed a petition for his release they
say
the so-called gag order prevents free
speech
spain's left-wing government has moved
to change the law
but that's come too late for herself
here say they'll continue to raise their
voices against the silencing
of the outspoken rapper
laura about manly al jazeera